welcome back to the three Muslims
yesterday we dropped the video about
Andrew Tate supposedly accepting Islam
today it's confirmed in sha Allah let's
see what is going on this is why I'm
Muslim any Christian who believes in
good and understands the true battle
against evil must convert
so be patient indeed the promise of
Allah is truth and he quotes Quran 30
60.
alhamdulillah and just to give you guys
some context you know wondering what's
even going on there's men that think
that they're women that are now
preachers in churches and the churches
are allowing it subhanallah stuck for
Allah so this is what Andrew Tate is
speaking about this is why a Muslim bro
there should be no there should be no
more like people wondering oh is he is
he not it makes me really happy the
reason it makes me happy is because
videos that we did talking about I was
saying so why aren't you Muslim why are
you Muslim I'm like he's looking at it
from you know this is the truth because
it agrees with things I stand for you
know and I'm like okay that's not the
worst thing in the world why aren't you
Muslim and now finally he's coming to
the truth he's accepting Islam and he's
actually capitalizing on the realization
that you know this is not something that
God would stand for and this religion is
actually standing for what God you know
Allah tells us to stand for I think it's
beautiful man alhamdulillah I'm very
very happy it's nearly impossible to use
black magic on Muslims because they are
so close to the source of their power
and protection by praying daily their
souls are divinely protected the average
Christian only prays when they have hard
times and then forget God completely
these long periods without prayer leave
their souls susceptible to negative
forces proof the average Christian is
easily Psy upped by the television and
does not strongly contest the
godlessness around them
that's facts bro
um I think this is this is very like
um alignment in alignment with what he
was saying on fresh and fit when he was
like if you're tolerant to everything
you stand for nothing something like
that yeah and and it's very true because
at the end of the day if you want to
have values by definition you're going
to agree with some people you're going
to disagree with other people yeah um
yeah but what do you think yeah and he
wouldn't often give the example he gave
it a lot the example of like Christians
and how they don't stand for anything
and people make basically a muck of that
religion and Islam Muslims stand for
something and people are not willing to
disrespect Islam they're not willing to
disrespect Muslims and when they do they
have basically very very harsh um
outcomes in their life and I'm not
saying that's something that should
happen but even in the case that for
example one person mocked Muslims he was
given like 24 7 surveillance
um by you know protective bodyguards and
everything his car ended up flipping and
killing everyone in it subhanallah it's
like Muslim doesn't even have to get
involved in still you know Allah deals
with these people
I reserve the human right to hold my own
beliefs and practice them as I see fit
and I allow all other people the same
right to believe and act as they wish
so he has like 41 tenants or like 41 I
guess points of like you know 41 tenants
41 tenants of Tate or something like
that okay I think this was pretty
self-explanatory yeah I do want to
comment on this uh yeah go for it I want
to kind of jump on this not to criticize
a brother you know he's our new brother
in Islam he's going to have a lot of
learning too obviously like we all did
when we first started practicing Islam
but I want to call this out now it's not
about Tate it's not about Andrew it's
about Islam it's about a brother coming
and accepting the truth he might make 41
tenants
um
if any one of those tenants goes against
Islam and I'm not saying that one did
but if any of them do end up going
against Islam in any capacity uh be
careful because it's not about Tate it's
about Islam right and if me or him or
anyone says something that goes against
Islam you know we need to politely be
checked corrected no this is [ __ ] I was
I was doing a coaching call yesterday
with one of my clients and I was
literally bringing up Robert Green's
book the 40 Laws of Power and I was
telling him about one of the laws how
like when it comes to like Victory know
when to stop like don't exceed your mark
you know because we were talking about
like goal setting and how to not burn
out how to take it gradually right so we
were like you want to do x amount of
workouts per week just to start with and
he's like what if I could do more and I
was like nah bro stop at that you know
know when to stop and I brought up I
even brought up the point that you
mentioned too I was like
don't use the 40 laws you know even even
when I said laws I caught myself because
I was like that's kind of cringe you
know because you know in a secular I
guess divisive setting sure these are
man-made principles and ideologies so I
told them I was like take that with a
grain of salt too it's not a law in the
eyes of like Allah like a legislative
Authority you know it's just it's a law
by this Robert green guy but it's true
you know know when to stop you don't
want to burn out
um so I do see what you mean bro yeah
100 and um
just given and this is not me trying to
criticize him like I said there are
going to be things he's going to have to
adjust to islamically that's just how it
is for every single person the process
you know had had to slightly adjust in
some cases but this they had to change
like everything right he was pretty
close I guess this time to begin with
but it's about to change like everything
bro so you know educate is no different
he's gonna have to change some things in
his life so I don't want him
um you know kind of seeing himself as as
like an authority figure in any capacity
other than the fact that he has a lot of
say over common people that listen to
him and there are a lot of people that
listen to him so I just I I'm seeing
something that could potentially be
dangerous because if he starts to
associate Islam with himself in some
kind of like I don't want to say
prophetic manner but in some kind of
like you know
um authoritative manner I don't want him
to start instructing people and saying
things that are aren't exactly in line
with Islam
um and at the same time we want to wish
we want to Hope good for our Muslim
brother too yeah you know we'll we'll
give him the benefit of the doubt for
now because again nothing's nothing's
out there nothing's confirmed in terms
of anything going against it and we want
to give him patience to a girl love of
Allah is in the sorry love of Allah is
the power of the heart the sustenance of
the heart the light of the heart and
that was a quote from Evil I was uh one
of the classicals
that's beautiful alhamdulillah I'm very
very happy he's you know he's he's
coming to the truth he's coming to Islam
he's accepted the truth
um I'm glad he's quoting the Quran
including um you know Scholars of Islam
I think maybe I'll be fair
the reason I pointed that last point out
is because he's making his tenants right
but he's also quoting the Quran he's
quoting quoting classical Scholars as
well so I do want to refer to him in
that respect which is yeah and he had
his tennis ball for Years bro even
decades a lot of them he was talking
about on Rumble that he made a lot of
these with his father before he passed
away you know and these were just like
kind of like compilations that they've
kind of gathered about their life their
wisdom and again pre-islam
um for him and definitely as a
non-muslim for his father unless he was
Muslim secretly
I want to say that not only does educate
have Muslims around him he has
connections he just did he just recorded
with Muhammad hijab I'm sure he can hit
him up and ask him a question if he
needs something you know he has Muslims
around him inshallah that will educate
him and encourage him to take the next
steps what he doesn't need is you know
half a million people or or freaking
half a billion people running at him
telling him you know do this do that let
the brother be you know he he has people
supporting him he has connections and as
big as he is
everyone even like the higher higher end
you know dies and Scholars would want to
reach out to him and if he has access to
those you know those guys he doesn't
need us he doesn't need you know random
people on the internet telling him what
to do just make dot for him just like us
just to make do out for him keep you
know make videos whatever supporting him
but don't tell him do this this and that
insha Allah inshallah I have nothing
else to say man I just wanted to say
that make though apart but you said it
beautifully bro I love my buttock stay
tuned guys tomorrow Insha'Allah we're
doing a live stream at 12 p.m Eastern
Standard Time sharp message to Abba and
preach because we saw their latest video
that they made after we made a response
to them inshallah so stay tuned for that
[ __ ]